foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI the sisters helping
make sure the food we eat isn't
endangering animals there are so many
orangutans lives have been completely
destroyed
and we put your questions to the man in
charge of Scotland the new first
Minister Hamza Youssef
thank you
hello this is your Weekly News show FYI
stick with us for the latest on all the
top stories and we're going to start
with one of the most amazing survival
stories we've ever heard it took place
in a part of the Amazon rainforest
that's in Colombia one of the most
extreme environments on Earth hot humid
and full of dangerous creatures
it's here that a small aircraft
crash-landed in the middle of nowhere
four children escaped the crash
relatively unhurt but sadly the three
adults they were with including their
mother didn't survive
so the children were left completely
alone the oldest only 13 the others nine
four and just one
and amazingly they survived for 40 days
until they were found by a Colombian
military search party
they'd eaten bags of flour from the
plain and rainforest fruits their first
words not surprisingly whether they were
very hungry the children are now
recovering in hospital and have been
reunited with their father and their
grandparents
we're joined by Adventurer and Wildlife
presenter Steve bakshaw Steve e filmed
in many remote jungles how amazing is it
that these children survived well we do
a lot of expeditions in jungles and it's
always a hard environment to work in but
we always have modern equipment with us
we're prepared for every eventuality we
have you know all the food we need we
have we have hammocks and and sleeping
bags and everything that we need to make
sure that we are absolutely comfortable
and they had next to nothing the ability
to to be able to survive and even Thrive
during that time is phenomenal for
anyone but for it to be done by a group
of children the youngest of whom was one
year old is completely beyond my my
understanding
significant was that the children belong
to a rainforest tribe themselves
I think it's everything you know they
would have grown up in this environment
and able to use it to their advantage
all the things that we would be
terrified by to them would be an
opportunity they would know how to to
gather water easily and be able to drink
it without getting sick which you know
would probably turn our stomachs they're
also going to be well aware of what they
need to do to make sure they avoid
things like like mold and fungus growing
on you like like bug bites and the
things that that can come from that
um so yes their their inherent knowledge
and experience it is a massive part of
of why they're here at all and how they
manage to flourish
[Music]
for chocolate eating everything from
chocolate bars to lollies it would
probably make their milk taste extra
delicious but is it fake news or fat
we'll let you know later
[Music]
now to Scotland where the country's new
leader Hamza Yusuf is just two months
into his job as first Minister FYI was
invited to Scotland's beautiful Capital
City Edinburgh to meet him and put
forward questions
Scotland is the second largest of the
UK's four nations with around five and a
half million people living here they're
still only a tenth of England's
population like Wales and Northern
Ireland it's had its own government for
over 20 years the systems known as
Devolution and means each nation has
control over certain things in their
country such as the NHS and education
though some decisions are still taken by
the UK government back in London
along with Wales Scotland leads on
giving young people a voice they're the
only UK Nations that let young people
vote for their politicians from the age
of 16. in England and Northern Ireland
the voting age is 18. I'm here in
Edinburgh at the headquarters of the
Scottish government St Andrews house
today they're taking part in a very
special event that happens once a year
the cabinet takeover to make sure that
Scottish children really get their say
the three issues obviously that were
raised we will absolutely follow up on
mostly issues I thought they were so so
powerful hey young people across
Scotland get to put their ideas to the
first Minister well things are like we
want to to change is like looking out
like the key issues are like really
affecting children right now and they
feel the meeting does achieve results
I think they are listening to us because
over the years a few things have been
turned into real things
free bus passes for all Scottish young
people aged 5 to 21 came in as a direct
result of one of these sessions creating
policy developing policy coming up with
ideas that affect young people that
should be done with young people and
after the cabinet takeover my chance to
put FYI viewers questions to Hamza who's
leader of the ruling Scottish national
party the SNP can you tell me about your
job and what you do so I'm the first
minister of Scotland I've been in the
job for just over 10 weeks and I lead
the Scottish government and the biggest
honor of my life well growing up did you
ever think you'd actually become the
first Minister not at all you know my
family history and Heritage is one that
my grandfather came here in the 1960s
from Pakistan and I don't think he ever
thought in two generations time that his
grandson could end up being the first
minister of Scotland now that I am in
position I hope that particularly young
people of color young Muslim boys girls
can look at the highest office in the
country and say well you know what maybe
one day I could be there too so now I
have some questions from an FYI News
Club at cumbernauld Academy
once you've got your oven too high when
new film is turned off water what you're
going to try to do about us
[Music]
a question from the FYI club
and I want to thank them for that
question because the cost of living is
far too high you know I've just heard
from a group of members of the
children's Parliament and members of the
Scottish youth Parliament and one of the
issues that raised with me was children
taking on the worries of their parents
so they might overhear their parents
talking about money issues that will
feed into their anxiety it will make
life really difficult for them it
affects their friendships it affects
their schoolwork is there anything
specific that you're doing we've
introduced something called the Scottish
child payment it's a unique payment
they're only available here in Scotland
is helping to lift children directly out
of poverty
as new first Minister how will you
support lgbtq plus rights in Scotland
three as a minority my whole life and I
know what it's like to feel like you
don't belong and therefore I've got a
duty to make sure our lgbtq plus
Community particularly our trans
community at the moment I've got a duty
to make sure that I'm not only
protecting them which I will do but I'm
also advancing their rights we can't
ignore the fact that when we look at
police statistics and there's still far
too much rampant homophobia I want every
lgbtq plus person in the country to know
that it's me as first Minister they've
got somebody that will not just offend
them but Advance their rights where they
can yeah we really need an environment
where people can just be free and safe
to be who they are yeah 100 I mean I I
remember when I was a young Muslim
growing up in Scotland and I didn't feel
safe I didn't feel like I belonged and
that was a horrible feeling and I
definitely don't want anybody in our
lgbtq plus Community but anybody in
Scotland ever feel like that again
figures regarding Ukrainian refugees
suggests Scotland has taken around
double the number of refugees for its
population size compared to England and
it's an issue Hamza Yusuf feels strongly
about
so we are for example we'd look at
Ukrainian refugees we're making sure
that in Scotland first of all we provide
a home to as many of those refugees as
we can I'm really upset actually at some
of the discussion the political
discourse around refugees around
immigrants around Asylum Seekers I think
it's too negative I think we have you
know two parties and the conservatives
and labor party who seem to what a race
to the bottom when it comes to refugees
I also think it's really important that
we give illegal and safe routes for
Asylum Seekers and those that are
seeking to migrate here because if we
don't have safe routes unfortunately the
only option available is unsafe Roots
those small boats and instead of trying
to deport people to Rwanda whatever the
UK government is trying to do that we
should create safe legal routes because
our country needs it too
the Scottish national party's main aim
has always been to become a completely
independent country separate from the
rest of the UK but the UK government has
blocked any more votes on this by the
Scottish people
[Music]
under your leadership well will Scotland
see another push for Independence if so
what will it look like
yes there's a short answer the future of
our country should be in the hands of
the people that live here they should
make the decisions that are in the best
interests of this country and we've got
a UK government I'm afraid that often
asks that uh in in the worst interest of
Scotland unfortunately we've got a UK
government that denies us the right to
referring them so we'll then have to
make every election including the next
general election about the issue of
Independence well thank you so much for
taking the time to answer my questions
we really appreciate it thank you so
much thank you
hey Scarlett look at this can you
believe it's been nearly five years
since Greta Thornburg did her first
Friday School strike outside the Swedish
Houses of Parliament when she was just
15. her climate change protests have
just become a part of our lives and
she's finally held her last school
strike after 251 weeks as she's
graduated from her Swedish High School I
mean it's crazy to think that just one
girl's Friday School strikes sparked a
whole worldwide Movement we will not be
silenced because we are the change and
change is coming whether you like it or
not
[Applause]
she's doing such an inspiration to our
generation yeah absolutely now around
the same time Greta started her strikes
two British sisters launched a petition
to stop rainforest destruction Asher and
Gia had heard about how huge areas of
rainforest were being destroyed to make
way for palm oil plantations the girls
were shocked that many orangutans were
losing their rainforest home and
becoming endangered as a result palm oil
is used in many everyday products
including lots of the food we eat and
three years ago the girls took a
petition to Kellogg's to discuss
changing their policy on palm oil well
recently Asha and Gia went back to
Kellogg's and were delighted that
they're here with us now so Asha ji I
thought you guys decide to start your
petition
so back in 2018 we were watching a palm
oil documentary about an orangutan
rehabilitation center and our lives had
been completely destroyed by the palm
oil industry it was saying about how
palm oil is in like everyday products so
we just out of Interest we were eating a
box of chocolates and we turned it over
and we realized palm oil was in it so we
set up a petition on change.org it's
really blown up and I think recently we
reached a million signatures so so
guarded Kellogg's get involved
um well they saw our petition online and
they sent us a letter and they said you
know like we really want to meet with
you it's amazing that such a big brand
you know wanted to get involved and see
if there's anything they can do to
improve their their palm oil consumption
that they're using yeah the fact that
even children like knew what was going
on yeah I think they really felt like we
got to start taking changes yeah so what
did Kellogg's agree to there is now a
plan of how they would get completely
sustainable palm oil by 2025 like
tracing the Palmer all the way back to
the plantation where it's come from
because actually like Palmer was one of
the most sustainable crops that you can
use if it's like produced correctly
recently you went back to Kellogg's to
check up on their progress so how did
that meeting go
um it went quite well we were mainly
just checking up on all the targets and
they are working towards their goals do
you think Kellogg's will be able to meet
all their goals by 2025 well they were
actually positives that they would so
it's just up to us to make sure that
they actually do well you guys are doing
an amazing job thank you so much for
joining us thank you thank you
[Music]
now our Australian dairy cows really
being fed chocolate the answer is yes
it's a fact the farmer gives his heart a
whole range of products from the local
Chocolate Factory that would otherwise
grow to waste he says his cows love it
all plain or milk chocolate and produce
excellent milk and yes some of it does
go into chocolate milk drinks
[Music]
finally today we're going to end with
two amazing sporting Milestones firstly
tennis the Serbian Novak Djokovic has
just broken the men's record for major
tournaments one
his victory at the French Open took his
tally of what are called Grand Slam
Tournament wins to a phenomenal 23.
overtaking the Spaniard Rafael Nadal on
22 and the Swiss Roger Federer who
retired on 20. Djokovic is now level
with the great women Champion Serena
Williams and just one behind Margaret
Court
and of course the other great sporting
achievement is Manchester City's treble
adding the Champions League to their
premier league and FA Cup victories well
joining us now from Manchester is our
very own presenter and mad man city
Super Fan Braden so Braden what have you
got there
oh well I've only got the Premier League
in one and and the Champions League in
the other yeah City you've done the
trouble and I am super happy so you're
in Istanbul for the Champions League
final what was that like it was
absolutely amazing I mean I couldn't
have enjoyed any more to be honest with
you why is it so special that you're
winning the treble
I mean with a second team in England to
do it because we've won our first ever
UEFA Champions League you predicted all
of this in a surprise meeting with
manager Pep Guardiola back in 2016 when
he first came to Man City didn't you yes
so on pep guardiola's first day in
Manchester little Brayden was tripped
into getting a taxi with him
it's really you I am
I am it's really really yes I am
thank you so much for joining us Braden
and we're gonna leave you some pictures
of Braden celebrating in the inevitable
rain see you next time bye he's
absolutely chucking it down the
atmosphere is building City you've got
all three
and it's getting Lively
room
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign